وضع بريطانيا المثقل بالاضطرابات على وشك
ان يصبح اكثر ارباكا يخاطر رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني الذي لم يمضي على توليه قياده
الحكومه ثلاثه اشهر بفوضه جديده في البلاد
بدايه العام المقبل مع رفضه مطالبا نقبات
برفع الاجور
فالاضرابات تتضاعف عددا ورقعه انتشارها
تتسع لتشمل قطاعات عده بعضها يشهد اضرابا
لاول مره كادرابات قطاعين الممرضين
والاسعاف في ديسمبر اضافه الى تهديد
نقاباتها بالمزيد من الاضرابات في يناير
ما يندر بمرحله مقلقه قد يواجهها
البريطانيون في عام 2013
قال قول بريطانيين ان انعكس على شيء
فسيكون على اداء الحكومه حيث تشير
استطلاعات الراي الى تراجع شعبيه حزب
المحافظين الذي يحمله عمال القطاع العام
مسئوليه التعطيل حياه الناس ودفعهم
للاضراب كماذن الاخير
ومع اجره عن تحقيق مطالب النقابات لاسباب
يقولوا انها اقتصاديه يتجه سوناك الى فرد
قوانين تضبط حركه الاضرابات قوانين تثير
الجدل في بلد يعطي قيمه كبيره لحريه
الاحتجاج
هؤلاء العمال
الظروف للموظفين واذا كان ذلك يعني اضراب
العمال فليكن ولكن اذا جعلت ذلك مخالفه
للقانون فانا لا اعتقد ان هذا امر عادل
تضامن النقابي متفق على ان المزيد من
الاضرابات هو الطريق الوحيد للمضي قدما
بدء من قطاع الصحه مرورا بالبريد وحتى
قطاع السكك الحديديه ومع اتجاه السونات
لطرح قوانين للحد من تحركات العمال لهذا
لا يبدو ان النقابات التي تملك زخم
الاضطرابات تنوي التراجع عن خطوطتها قبل
تحقيق مطالبها من لندن عروب عبد الحق
العربيه